it's just after 10 30 p.m and Salman
abadi has detonated his bomb in the city
room the foyer of the Manchester Arena
seconds later a member of the public
calls 999.
explosive Manchester Arena yes
right okay where you've done it was
anybody injured yes Lord at 1037
Northwest Ambulance Service requests
assistance from Northwest Fire Control
stating reports of an active shooter I'm
being told the shots the shot has been
fired
right okay so you you've told you that
then no one of my colleagues so a
colleague has told you that somebody
there's an active shooter
that's that's what I'm getting told
right okay but the police have not
confirmed that three minutes later Andy
Berry the senior Fire officer that night
receives a call from Northwest Fire
Control police request that he sends the
firefighters to a car park near the
arena instead he sends them to Phillips
Park Fire Station three miles away at 10
42 the first armed police officers
arrive at Victoria train station and
make their way to the city room
paramedic Patrick Ennis arrives he had
been at Central Manchester ambulance
station and decided to self-deploy he
calls ambulance control
foreign
Manchester police's duty officer Chief
Inspector Dale Sexton suspects the
explosion may be part of an ongoing
terrorist act and declares a prepared
plan operation Plato this restricts the
response of ambulance and fire Crews for
fear of another attack it means
paramedics don't enter the scene for 43
minutes although both a senior police
officer and paramedic Ennis radio in
requesting more help in the city room
the youngest victim of the attack
eight-year-old Safi russos is carried
out of the city room by two police
officers and a member of the public on a
makeshift stretcher made from an
advertising board she has taken 102
meters to an exit on Trinity way but
there's no ambulance one has arrived on
the opposite side of the complex
the ambulance service Commander Daniel
Smith and Dr Michael Daly arrive at the
train station they don't go any further
instead they set up a casualty clearing
site on the station Concourse 100 meters
from the explosion site
it's now 30 minutes after the blast
there are six paramedics in the area
along with a doctor but none are in the
city room where many casualties remain
six ambulances arrive together on
station approach but Safi is still on
the other side of the complex it's 17
minutes before an ambulance is flagged
down by a police officer to take her to
hospital at 11 40 she's pronounced dead
after losing too much blood
at 11 17 another victim of the attack 28
year old John Atkinson is pulled from
the city room to the Footbridge just
outside he has leg injuries it's several
minutes before he's carried on a crowd
control barrier to the casualty clearing
Station 22 minutes later he suffers a
fatal cardiac arrest
at 11 42 the first person being treated
at the casualty clearing point is taken
to hospital by ambulance an hour and 11
minutes after the explosion
at 12 36 the first fire and rescue
service engine arrives was senior
officer Andy Berry two more engines turn
up Andy Barry tells crew they shouldn't
go into the station until he has
permission from the Chief Fire officer
but fire teams decide to enter the
building and assist other Emergency
Services over the next two hours despite
their orders the last injured victims
are taken from the casualty clearing
station to hospital at 2 46 a.m more
than four hours after the explosion